hello YouTube Chancellor's this is guns
in here and today I'm going to discuss
with you some interesting analyses about
Bishop sacrifice on at seven which is
also known as a Greek gift let's start
with a game which I have recently played
on Internet let's start with a French
defense and had this position black has
castle on the Queen King side now if you
can look at the blacks position over
here this night on e7 and what it does
is actually weakened somewhat at seven
square and today in my rest of the
videos I'm going to show you how this
Bishop sacrifice on at seven going to
work for the white and it will help the
white to win the game so let's say B sub
sacrifice on at seven and King take this
fish up and now white will come with a
knight check and there are therefore
Square where black king can escape from
them two are really bad if the King is
moved to the h8 square Queen will coming
or the h5 Square and this is made in two
so that's not good and if the king is
coming on at six square it will matter
with the discovered check and black
loses the Queen so that's not good
either
so let's take first option if the King
is going back on to g8 Square where here
the White Queen will come on h5 Square
and now the 30s at seven mate so the
only good move here for the black is
move this look on the e-file and giving
some breathing room to the black black
King and well widely in this case white
will continue with the head seven check
King is moving aside again the Queen
check now this time 90s coming in
between and white will give the night
check and fair Kim King is moving on
east seven square and he will meet up
with a Bishop Jack now there are two
ways to block the shack first is moving
the F pawn further which was met by the
Queen May Queen check and this is made
and another another option is if the
night is coming in between this Bishop
check is really deadly because King has
no space to escape so black has to take
this Bishop and black will be made by
the screen
so that's a g8 now what happened if the
king is moving further which is g6
square well here h4 is really deadly
because H files coming in you can
already see there is no place for escape
escaping the black King because it is
surrounded by codes it is like its own
pawn structure so let's say a black
ignore this threat and try to play some
random moves like moving the crook over
here then this H Phi is coming in if the
black king is moving on at six square
this will make either losing the Queen
and if black king is trying to come in
further it will
checkmate it by white so and let's let's
say like what black can do about this
but unfortunately in this position black
has no move no PCs are capturing that H
v square so the at most is this Roop can
come on the edge file and anyways white
will give you a chat to the black King
and if the black group take this pawn
this Queen check is really deadly
because why it has to there's one square
to escape and it will met it will
checkmate it here so let's take another
example now if you can look at the
blacks position over here the 90s on d7
rather than in previous game it was on
e7 square so the fight more water will
slightly change but anyways we will I
will give you an accession of how this
Bishop sacrifices work in this game as
well so that will take this Bishop and
now it comes with an eye check and again
there's two options first King will go
back in this case Queen will come on the
h5 square and again the threat is at 7
made so crucial Duke has to move but in
this case instead of going this way
first will go in this way so Queen will
take this f7 Square and check the black
King King has to move over here and
again the same models according to
previous game and the point where the
black King in coming on the e7 Square
this is made so that's the g8 and if if
the king is coming further in g6 Square
again the black white will play the h4
square
at four and if you can see over here the
white is already castle on the kingside
so h4 is somewhat weakened and if black
is thing he can attack on this h4 but H
fire is deadly over here and let's see
how if the black sari
Lukas take this pawn then white has a
nice combination of queen and a knight
so what we're going to do is first keep
the d3 chat and now King has none no
square to escape so he has to give this
like cover the stack by the FF 1 and
here white will take this point by um
pissant
and again the for the black there's only
one move so he will take this pawn now
we will give a check or to a king by
moving the Queen on f3 and White has
like black has to go only to the e7
square notice that if the black king is
going on the g6 square then this was met
by the screen check and again if there's
only one place and it's been met by the
like black loses the Queen so that's not
good so King has King has to move to the
e7 square so what we're going to do over
here is delay the capture of this book
and it will give a check on the EPSA 1
EPSA 1 square and again clacking has 1
square to escape which is here d6 and
now the White will capture this room and
what it does is it is it's giving a
threat the black which it will move the
knight to the epsilon square it will
folk the king and a queen so black can't
take this pawn and if you look at the
vice president over here it's materially
white ease up over here and it will be a
good game for the white so let's take
another good game which I personally
feel that it's a good explanation of
Greek gift because the reason behind is
here the Queen has moved from his
original position so let's see how it's
work out for the white now so white will
again Bishop check and this long now the
night check and again those two options
if the King is moving back so the Queen
check and if the like there's only one
wait so the crook has to move on this
side and the movers are same and
now King is coming on e7 and Bishop
check now if you can look at the blacks
position over here black has really one
really good square to escape and so what
black gonna do over here is flush block
this Shack and when the queen is going
queen is taking this g7 square then
black King will run away on the d8
square and now if someone can look look
at this position against and can say oh
the black white is losing over here but
no it's not let's see how first quite
will exchange the screen and there are
two ways to X take this screen first
let's see if the black take this one by
night well in this case white will take
this pawn and you can already see that
if this cook point is going further it
will fuch the group candlelight and not
only that it will give you this cover
check looking so black has to take this
pawn and white will take back with the
night and you can already see the white
is already to pawn up over here it's a
good game for the white let's take an
another option which King take this
Queen well again in this case white will
take this form and let's say if the
black is tried to save the shell the
rook well again in this case white will
move the pawn further and it again black
tries to save the night then this is
Queenie
this is queening and black will lose the
rook and it will be a good king for the
white so let's say the other option
where the white is coming white king is
coming further on j6 crap well here the
h4 is not deadly because queen is
already moved from the original position
so what we're going to do here is
putting the Queen on the g4 square and
it will force the discover check to the
black king so black has to do something
about this there are two it was kept
from this first option is F F Phi where
in this case there's a nice little move
which is Queen move on the D so I h h4
square and what it does is threatening
at 7mate here so the only way to defend
is to move this point further where in
this case y will continue with the line
with queen check and if the black king
take this Knight
there's a nice little mate and let's see
if you can find it by euro and you can
pause the video and you can find it by
own I'm going further right now so what
this Knights little move is called f3
and now what it does is threatening h4
mate so let's see if the black group
moves over here this is made so that's
not good and adoption is that like night
and coming between hell again in this
case we white will move with the hedge
for chat and if the King moves over here
this is checkmate and if Black Knight
take this pawn there and this is just
checkmate for dealing checkmate for a
while
so now it's checked to the king and if
the King moves further this is checkmate
and if the King moves another way this
is checkmate as well so that was the f5
and let's say app six option which was
met by the knight check and King has to
move over here because if it move over
here this is checkmate
so black King has to move over here and
this will meet by the Queen check which
which will allow black ink so temporary
take this Knight and here the black
black White Queen will take this rook
and let's say black couldn't identify
those head over here and it played the
night over here it will simply checkmate
the black King so black has to do
something about this checkmate so first
it will check capture this pawn and it
will catch white and capture back and if
the black capture this pawn here White
will Castle on the Queen side and the
threat over here here is like if random
moves from the back like this then this
will make the checkmate
so that's not good and if the black see
this threat and if it's tried to avoid
something and he's try to do some queen
trades then white will simply avoid this
and this Queen is moving over here and
this time checked by the pawn and let's
if the blur King move over here this is
checkmate and if the black King move
over here
the bishop check will allow black Kings
to go away from the knight and you can
already see the advice white is really
good over here in fact white is really
better because you can see this Knight
is going nowhere this bit of this rook
is take ages to come out this Queen has
really few places to go and this Bishop
on a diagonal where is nothing doing
nothing so initially white is really
good over here
well thank you for watching my video and
I'll see you next time
please feel free to comment on my video
bye
you